the entirety of the media the left and
many uh basically every Trump supporter
can't stop ragging on Ron DeSantis and
uh talking about his Failure to Launch
Trump has been roasting DeSantis of
course because he's going to be running
against him it's entirely predictable
and I'm interested to see if Ronda
Sanders can improve there's a lot to
talk about we did talk quite a bit the
other day about his announcement and
we'll go over that just a little bit in
response in reference to the responses
that we're seeing because this really is
the big story I mean this is the
aftermath the day after Rhonda Rhonda
Santos announcing that he is running but
we do have a lot of news a lot of really
big and a lot of really great news
Target lost 9 billion dollars in their
market cap following what people are
referring to as the Bud Light effect
that companies are scared people are
scared they're going to lose value on
their stock when there's boycotts the
boycotts seem to be working bud light's
not recovering Target panics their stock
goes down
so we're talking about that plus a whole
bunch of other crazy news get this New
York has voted to freeze deposits at
Capital One and KeyBank get this because
they did not state how they would stop
discrimination what else were they
supposed to do I just there we go we're
like ESG is coming to you if you use
these Banks there it is so before we get
started my friends head over to
castbrew.com and join the cast Brew
Coffee club or purchase some Castro
coffee this is our company we're
sponsoring ourselves and with your
support buying our delicious Casper
coffee we're gonna be setting up coffee
shops we're going to be impacting
culture directly and we are going to
build that parallel economy as many of
you are boycotting Bud Light many of you
are boycotting Target and probably a lot
of other companies as well maybe Netflix
maybe Disney we have to set up new
companies to replace the bad ones so go
to casper.com if you like coffee I
happen to enjoy it quite a bit and try
our rise with Roberto Jr or Appalachian
nights our signature Blends plus we've
got Colombian and French roast K-Cups
are on the way again casper.com don't
forget also head over to timcast.com
click that join us button become a
member because we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you
tonight at about 10 10 p.m Eastern on
the front page of timcast.com and if
you've been a member for at least six
months or you sign up at the 25 per
month level you get access to the chat
room where you can submit questions to
call into the show and ask us and our
guests a question
so again tipguest.com don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is rep Wesley hunt
thank you so much for having me happy to
be here really appreciate it man thanks
for coming do you want to introduce
yourself sure my name is Wesley hunt I'm
the congressman for a Congressional
District 38 in Houston Texas is a
greater greater Houston area suburb
North Northwest a little bit about me
born and raised in Houston so I actually
get to interrupt the city that I grew up
in which is pretty awesome military
family my dad's a retired lieutenant
crow in the Army sister went to West
Point my family first I went to West
Point my family second my brother is
also a West Point graduate so there's
about 60 years worth of military service
just in my immediate family wow uh got
out the military
um uh did eight years active duty as an
Apache helicopter pilot uh flew 55
combat air missions in Baghdad that was
the last time I was actually really cool
[Laughter]
spit downhill ever since from that now
you're doing all right
guys I don't know like Congressman
Apache pilot I'll take the I'll take the
ladder yeah um the finish up there uh
went to grad school at Cornell
University uh earned three master's
degrees in four years at Cornell did a
mass in business public administration
industrial Labor Relations wow moved
back home to Houston ran for Congress
and here we are all right let's meet a
nutshell brother
I'm married I got three little kids I
got a four month old little boy
four-year-old little girl American dream
it is the American dream and and a
two-year-old little girl that next week
I'm thinking about passing some
legislation to get her on a terrorist
watch list because she's an animal okay
this will be fun thanks for joining us
thank you for having me bro Sheamus is
here I'm a cartoonist
[Applause]
you once drew a picture of helicopter I
once drew a picture of a helicopter
that's actually true it looked real it
looked very real so no big deal you know
it'd be good but I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we release
a cartoon at least once a week usually
twice a week next week we're going to be
releasing three cartoons so you'll go
over there check it out we also release
at least one cartoon a week behind our
paywall at freedomtunes.com if you want
to become a member and support what we
do cool I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com I'm happy to be
here
and I am serge.com I'm ready to start
when you guys are let's just jump into
the obvious big news over the past day
we've got this from timcast.com Trump
roasts DeSantis 2024 presidential
campaign announcement quote wow the Des
Sanctus Twitter launch is a disaster
Trump said and uh we've got a bunch of
memes that all of these Trump supporters
are posting team Trump posted this is
probably one of the this may be one of
the worst ones Ron with the exclamation
point like Jeb and uh what is what is
this falling over is that is that a
rocket falling over is that what is that
supposed to be it's a failure to launch
it's supposed to be a rocket that shoots
up
from uh when Elon elon's rocket didn't
like take off probably that's what I
thought it looked like one of their
players yeah yeah
so this morning I was talking about this
too because you know the the
announcement comes yesterday at 6 p.m
we've now had a full 24 hours plus of
media reactions the media is going nuts
I don't really care like I don't like
their opinion to begin with but you've
got the left and the right basically
pointing at DeSantis being like yo that
was really really bad and there are
these DeSantis I don't know I don't know
is there what's a word for someone who's
like a die hard for DeSantis whatever it
doesn't exist maybe a distant no I'm
inventing it's a distantis a distantis
yeah there's stance
yes well they they are and they're on
Twitter and they're they're posting this
stuff and it's just like look man
that that Ron with the exclamation point
really does sum it up a lot and you were
saying this before the show yeah that he
could Jeb out yes and that's actually my
call I think he's getting ready to flame
out like we just saw yesterday he's
doing he's gonna jab out yeah you know
real quick and this is this is something
that's kind of near and dear to my heart
that's really important to me and that's
and that's loyalty so president Trump
has endorsed me the last two cycles and
so when he came out and announced back
in November I was literally it he
finished like the last syllable we
endorse him immediately because it's
really important to me he helped get me
here Ron DeSantis would not be the
governor of Florida if not for Donald
Trump and so what I'm seeing here is a
level of disloyalty I think he's going
to pay for ultimately and that's just
not how you treat someone that got you
this far he's 44 years old he's the
governor of the Free State of Florida
and by the way from what I could tell
he's done a pretty good job at it yeah
just be loyal to the person that got you
here in the first place and then you
could be The Heir Apparent for the
future but my fear is that he is being
talked into doing this by a lot of other
people that are going to make a lot of
money and basically what we saw
yesterday we were kind of talking about
it before the show how he looks like a
hostage patient right now he looks like
he's being held hostage to do this and I
think there are a lot of people in
Florida that simply want him to stay in
Florida and be the governor and do the
job that they elected him to do yeah
this is something that brought up was
brought up as we're setting everything
up well he's not going to win Florida
for two for two reasons people love
Trump and a lot of people in Florida who
vote for Santa's probably would choose
to vote for Trump but also the people
who really love DeSantis are going to be
like not to keep him here that's exactly
right you said this before the show
they're gonna have their cake and eat it
too they're going to get Trump as the
president and desensitize their governor
who would who would I would love to have
that and you brought that point up and
I've never I've actually never heard
that before that's absolutely spot on
because I was always looking at it from
like a head-to-head standpoint but if I
were literally a citizen that was living
in the Free State of Florida and based
on the last few years being in basically
Florida and Texas where I'm from I call
those the last two free states of our
Union and and the idea of the job that
he has done as Governor you mean to tell
me that I get to have President Trump on
top of this ticket and I get to keep
DeSantis as my Governor why in God's
they would I not want that I have I have
never heard that point it's a very
Salient Point too as well because it's
very simple I know you choose that but
we've had tons of people comment on this
show people have called in saying we
don't want our governor to leave yes
yeah so like sorry look it's he's going
to get termed out but he's got some time
left plenty of time
left no one here is saying oh DeSantis
has some horrible swap monster we hate
him we hope Trump destroys him it's the
opposite I want desensis to be
successful I don't think the best
possible move for him right now is to
leave Florida I could totally be wrong
about that I'm not making predictions
here but what I am saying is this
genuinely comes from a place of saying
all right there are so few good
political leaders in America today that
when there is one doing a really good
job in Florida and he's got a long
career ahead of him maybe it's not the
right time for him to run for president
he would also be I think what the second
youngest president or would it make him
the youngest that 44 second after after
JFK how old is Jack okay
oh look was he 42 no I'll look no you
won't let's get there
how old was JFK when he elected my
confused my computer froze so Hannah
might actually beat me that's not
oh wow 43 I'd be the second youngest
president oh my computer he's got time
but you know uh I was talking about this
this morning dude if if you're gonna sit
here and lie to defend DeSantis over his
lack of Charisma you'll lose and if
you're gonna come out and try and try
and defend that he has no Charisma with
but his policies are great that reminds
me of that Futurama bit where the
Amazonian women introduce the men to
their WNBA and they're like no Ken dunk
but good fundamentals it's like okay
dude the the the being the loud strong
voice is dunking you can be you can be
in all uh let's just let's just quit the
basketball there are tons of really
really great basketball football players
yeah you'll never remember their names
they're really well-rounded they they
they have really great stats and then
there's those those star players that
you just know are commanding the massive
salaries this is also so an important
point for people to consider and
something that is really lost on people
and this is some it's a mistake I made
by the way when uh I was looking at the
2016 election there were politicians
whose policies I liked more than Trump
and so I was saying those people should
have gotten the nomination at the time
now obviously Trump grew on me over the
years and I really like him now
but at the time my thoughts were well
this political leader has better
policies but the reality is a politician
is not just a set of policies they're a
presence they're a person they're a
leader they have to be capable of doing
certain things and one of the things
that whoever gets selected by the
Republicans to be the nominee has to be
able to do
is be charismatic enough to win a
general election now many people have
responded to this by arguing that Joe
Biden isn't charismatic okay Joe Biden
doesn't have good policies either what
Joe Biden had was a massive leg up he
had massive institutional support that
no Republican nominee is going to get so
saying Biden one of the worst candidates
of all time won so we don't have to be
very selective about the level of
Charisma our candidates have is not an
argument because guess what whoever ends
up winning in 2024 if it's a republican
Time Magazine isn't going to come out
several months from now with an article
about how every major institution in the
country coalesce to get him elected when
the Democrat nominee is chosen be it
Biden Time Magazine is going to show a
smiling Biden with a light blue
background shaking hands and no matter
which Republican it is they're going to
superimpose their face on Hitler's body
exactly I think Charisma does make a
difference I mean I said this before the
show but uh every politician I'm sure
you can speak to this surround
themselves with people who are able to
come up with strong policy it's part of
having a strong staff so
they're not always the person who has a
the front of the room they're not always
the person making speeches Chris makes a
huge difference uh Ron DeSantis team
just released that they fundraise 8.4
million dollars since his announcement
since his official launch yesterday in
uh 2019 Trump raised 24.8 million
dollars in the 24 hours after he
launched his re-election campaign there
is such a a serious
um weight to Charisma to leadership to
Persona and the numbers alone tell us
that DeSantis is not it I mean again I
think he's talented I'm happy for him to
have a long career I think we should
have a strong deep uh bench of
politicians who are really willing to
lead the country in the right direction
but you cannot deny that Donald Trump
has something wrong to San Francisco
real quick the fundraising for Trump
numbers was that you said 20 2019 2019.
he announces re-election campaign 24.8
million dollars unless can we look up uh
2015 yeah to see what he raised I'd be
curious because you had a really wide
field then I think at what 17 candidates
or whatever now you've got three or four
so that I've actually announced yeah
right right so I'd be interested to see
it's hard to do a one for you can't
really do a one-for-one comparison
because the total different numbers I'd
be willing to bet the reason I asked
though is that in 2015 Trump probably
raised a lot of money relative to what
you know to the field but then again I
mean everyone thought Cruz was going to
win very early on right it bounced
around a lot of people are pointing out
that uh at this time in Trump's uh first
campaign his polling was way way way
down yeah so we will see but guys look I
pulled up Barack Obama's announcement
from 2000 I think 2007. it was it was it
was fire it was it was passion he's got
this massive crowd of people he does
this slow build up and that's why
ah Barack Obama I'm announcing my
candidacy and Rising the raising the
voice everyone ah yeah Rhonda Sanders
went well I'm running for president to
uh lead the Great American comeback and
uh I'm like okay well this is another
important thing to consider which is
that presidential campaign spending has
been one of the number one predictors of
who gets elected for decades and Trump
actually broke that mold the kit the
Clinton campaign outspent Trump about
two to one and Jeb two by the way yeah
oh interesting in the primaries way more
than he's initially absolutely that
makes perfect sense to me though right
because no matter how much money people
throw at you even if you know I
shouldn't say no matter how much money
people throw at you because we know that
if you do have massive Capital behind
you in all of corporate America's got
your back yeah you're gonna have a
higher chance of success no doubt but
the fact that Trump was able to overcome
those odds is really really incredible I
mean and I would just encourage everyone
to to uh just quickly look up the charts
of campaign spending since the 1960s
you'll find that basically every single
election the person who outspent one
with the exception of trump vs Clinton
I I want to say I want to say I want to
tell you a quick story about about
Charisma and what Charisma really means
so a couple of months ago president
Trump came down to Waco Texas and did a
rally and I got to speak at the rally
and when Trump showed up to the rally it
was at an Airfield
so there were thousands of people
waiting in line four or five hours in a
day to go to this rally and do you know
how president Trump showed up
in his plane he does a low pass over the
crowd and you know the music he starts
playing at the rally danger zone
and then tax is around behind the stage
where there is a red carpet waiting
where he gets off the plane walks on the
red carpet onto the stage you know and
it's like I'm here yeah that's the
difference between what we saw yesterday
and what you will see at a trump rally
it's like comparing apples to orangutans
it's not even close there there is a
video that Trump put out that shows a
flyover with jets
The Descent a pack for DeSantis
superimposed jets with fake jet noises
flying over to santis it's not helping
guys like I know that it wasn't the
DeSantis campaign that did that someone
did and I'm just like Trump's got the
real flyover he was President like you
gotta know where you can and can't win
in in the pr space but that's correct no
question I've seen that the plane
pulling up I think I was in Leesburg I
can't remember the the the jumbo jet
pulling in slowly Trump walks right this
one walks right up to the stage and
there he is afterwards he walks down to
the barricades it's shaking hands with
everybody yes he is he is an 80s man and
he is he is a charismatic leader well
and I just want to throw this out there
again you can be a massive DeSantis fan
and still refuse to pretend that the
emperor is wearing clothes when he isn't
there's a lot of things to like about
DeSantis it's okay to say that he can
work on solving the problem of his lack
of Charisma we we were mentioned this a
moment ago if they did not give him
proper media training then he's in
trouble he's done if they did and that
was the best they could do
he's done he's done so also I will say
this too Rana Sanders peaked in November
after the election in November after the
midterm election where we didn't perform
as well that's exactly where the Santa's
Peak and he ended up winning Florida by
how much like 20 23 points and even one
in Miami won by this huge margin yeah
yeah and even back in November he was
still behind the president and if you
look at the polling if you look at uh
the attraction ever since it's just been
a precipitous fall off ever since
November and he's not getting better
we had the story from the
post-millennial DeSantis loses 10 points
Trump gains 13 in latest CNN SSRS
presidential poll that's correct not a
big fan of CNN polling you know but it's
a it's a data point is there a new poll
conducted by CNN just days before it
attendance announced that he would be
formally announcing they you know we can
see that his numbers are dropping
according to the poll
uh 53 of Republicans voters say they
would consider themselves as currently
supporting Trump while DeSantis guarded
only 26 compared to the previous data
set collected between March 8 to through
the 12th to Santa's lost 10 points while
Trump gained 13. yeah I I am telling you
when a lot of things that Trump has been
doing have been boosting him in the
polls and me personally I'm like I like
what he's doing going to Ohio yes East
Palestine that was absolutely fantastic
doing the McDonald's bit like I know the
menu better than you guys and
the funny thing is you want to win the
presidency you need good policies but
you are not selling someone look let's
put it this way if you're selling a
refrigerator to somebody and you knock
on their door and say my refrigerator's
got 200 watts of pure power with my
refrigerator if someone else walks up
and says you want the best refrigerator
you've ever seen in your life boom there
it is look at that thing shiny and
beautiful the pizzazz
obviously you need real policies yes but
Trump is the the
he's the crazy guy he's the loud he's
he's the loud man the salesman and a
Santa says the numbers guy and this is
important right because what people are
going to say is what's important is the
quality of the refrigerator guys we're
all trying to sell the same refrigerator
the question is who's the better
salesman
Trump's Trump's refrigerator might be a
little bit worse
maybe I mean we we saw a swamp monster
look I'm not saying Trump is perfect I
guess my main point with all of this is
when I see a poll that says DeSantis is
falling I don't regard this with joy
this doesn't make me happy it's not like
when Trump was crushing Jeb Bush or
these other politicians who I really
dislike it it's not enjoyable for me
because I do like DeSantis I don't think
this rivalry is good for the Republican
party I think it's bad for the
conservative movement but I'd be look
I'd be lying if I sat her and said
DeSantis is just as charismatic and
Trump and Injustice capable of exciting
people because it's not true let's do
the analogy this way you've got
roommates or family members and we've
all got to agree on which refrigerator
we're gonna get and you got Ron DeSantis
Trump and Joe Biden Joe Biden's
refrigerator is like from the 60s it's
broken completely and he can't even tell
you what's going on come on man he's
just like all right you don't have
questions he directs you to Kamala
Harris yeah I don't know what this is
and then Ron is giving this very very
straightforward quiet low pitch and then
Trump is giving you this loud boisterous
we're gonna have the best refrigerator
mark my words and everyone's like yeah
yeah screaming I want that one yeah well
but hold on and there's an important
Point here which is someone could hear
that analogy and still think I would
choose the better fridge and not the
better salesman okay that's true you
would but this isn't a question of us
picking a fridge for our house this is a
question of us picking a refrigerator
salesman to sell the fridge to the
entire country collectively by the way
exactly what are people going to buy
like what are people going to buy and I
think part of the criticism of trump is
always oh he's not dignified he's not
presidential enough but I think that's
why people relate to him he doesn't fit
a mold he's exciting he's funny he's
relatable in the same way that JFK was
sort of this young like breath of fresh
air to his era and he Jerusalem people I
think people are drawn to Trump because
he represents strength and not having to
conform with the kind of stodgy
Republican Party of the past I think
people like that uh change of pace
knowing that they can send him to talk
to Vladimir Putin you can send him out
into the world he will make you know
he's not 100 perfect all the time but he
does come through on a lot of his
promises and that's what people want
I'll tell you the most important point
Ron DeSantis accomplishments are
bolstered by a republican legislature
that sends him the bills that he can
sign and if he goes to the presidency
unless the Republicans win every Branch
he won't have that what we need and what
I think we need to be able to rely on is
not policy but executive action firing
bureaucrats agreed getting rid of the
deep State yeah criminal day one on day
one day one by the way immediately I I
feel confident that my best path towards
that is Donald Trump
Rhonda Sanders can come out and say
policy policy policy and I'll say how
are you going to get any of those
policies done with Democrats that's
right obstructing unless of course in
2024 Republicans win both houses both uh
Chambers which we have a shot at
absolutely if that's the case well so
then policy matters but if we're talking
about the best path forward it's going
to be we hedge our bets we want the best
case scenario and that is Trump may not
have the best policies because right
attendance really does have a great list
of policies though it's pretty good he's
good and going forward policy is the
best the best we've ever seen right but
Ronda santis his policies are actually
the Florida State Legislature it's not
just him so we don't know what we're
going to get with with the president
DeSantis it's real so my point is you
want policies vote for Congress vote
Republicans into Congress in the senate
make sure they win there and then Trump
signs whatever they give them right
we're talking about the presidency the
executive action we're not talking about
the legislature so but it's not just any
executive action it's executive action
for the first time we literally electing
a lame duck president on day one
oh man so he is completely unencumbered
by anything he is free yeah to do
literally whatever he wants on day one
yeah and the next two and a half years
it's all his show because he can't get
reelected that's exactly what we want
yeah we don't want anybody married to
the past we don't want anybody to
married to any of three letter agencies
it was sort of what he struggled with in
his first term which is that how do I
how do I do both how do I get my second
term he doesn't have to do both yeah and
that's exactly what the country wants
exactly the country exactly yeah yeah
and then whoever his vice president is
wherever that person that he picks is
going to be that's going to be a very
important person to move on to take his
policies for the future to get
Republicans reelected then but I cannot
imagine a world that we don't want him
walking in on day one and signing 167
executive executive orders overturning
the disaster that Biden has been for the
previous four years that's exactly what
the country wants right now and that's
why he's doing so well in the polling
and you were saying that he can't pick
uh DeSantis to be as vice president I
know a lot of people have floated at
Trump to Santa's ticket but they're full
from Florida for multiple reasons
they're both from Florida for multiple
reasons he's running I mean this is a
loyalty issue I mean president Trump is
big on loyalty uh this this level of
disloyalty really takes him out of that
competition and also both being from
Florida and we need every single
Electoral College vote going to 2024 as
possible so yeah so who do you think
he's going to pick who would you try to
be his VP do not tell president Donald
John Trump
nobody tells him nobody tells him what
to do but if you could make a suggestion
who would be your pick for VP I actually
today I had a few ideas a few months ago
and today I actually have no idea the
issue that we have to take we have to
take into account too is you are
absolutely right you were talking
earlier about the general election and
we're talking about Suburban women and
how we're going to lose a lot of them
kind of no matter what for a sundry of
different reasons what I like looking at
it focusing on is the growth that we
have seen
the black community
specifically black men
I put a clip up a couple of days ago
about Ice Cube and I'm talking Ice Cube
like like Mr NWA like Cube literally
railing on the Democrat Party and saying
that Democrats have been in charge for
the past 40 years and they have done
absolutely nothing for the black
community in the last 40 years and then
I saw some other polling that had
Joe Biden down 40 points amongst black
men wow I want to point to 2020 a couple
of years ago president Trump got the
highest vote the highest percentage of
votes for black men and modern history
for a republican at 18.7 percent if he
is able to ask retains 25 or more those
Suburban white women that we may not
pick up will be will be supplemented by
black men that do and will vote for
president Trump moving forward and when
I see Cube leaving I'm like this is
getting very interesting yeah and and
um obviously if black men are choosing
Trump these these liberal women they're
racist unless they do unless they do
they need to listen to uh the voice of
the marginalization we have to listen to
people of color their lived experience
right right so tell us what to do and
how to think I'm painting that uh Tim
Scott from South Carolina is the best
choice for VP yeah I think he would have
a yeah I think he has a fair shot I
think think again anybody that's not
from Florida we'll we'll have to see
kind of who shakes out but literally I'm
not going to even begin we want to guess
I can't I can't I literally can't guess
uh I think that's going to be solely up
to president Trump and I think he's
going to pick a great person you'll pick
the right person
um and I again a few months ago I
absolutely would have guessed but then
now you're seeing people running against
him and I don't know how he is going to
handle that in the long run yeah it'll
be interesting again that's why I was
lit with two like you don't tell them
what to do I mean let's let's just be
honest I like Tim Scott he's a good guy
yeah and and you I think we talked about
so much before the show but one of the
points was
it won't be DeSantis because he wants an
advantage in another state so any other
any other person that's a announcement
video had much more power I mean you're
saying that Santa's came off confused
and sort of timid and tired that's
that's not the case with what what Tim
Scott it was not the case I'd also like
to ask something
um just pertaining to what you said a
moment ago did you say that Trump got
the historic percentage of the black
vote in 2016 or 2020. that was it was
2020 probably 20 20. okay okay
was that up from 2016. yes it was from
2016 and I'm off I'm talking
specifically about black men black men
18.7 of black men and I found that the
fascinating stat because that's
literally how we make up the difference
I'm convinced of that at this point I
think uh Wall Street General ran a story
is saying that if the Democrats dip
below 80 of the black vote they can't
win it's it's actually mathematically
impossible yeah because that's their
base literally that's their base it's
even just 21 Republicans just win that's
it yeah that's it and that's why if you
look at what happened
oh I'm sorry I'm so sorry to interrupt I
just read a piece of information that
shocked me you said if it goes below 80
the Democrats can't win because 80
percent of black men supported Joe Biden
which was down from Hillary at 82
percent it looks like they're but
they're probably right there really
approaching that it's trending and by
the way he's doing abysmally drove by
right now is doing abysmally bad amongst
black men today and I think it's it's
it's it's a bunch of reasons why I mean
it's always inflation it's always the
economy when I'm in a barber shop man
it's it's absolutely hilarious to to
listen to people that were before like I
can't stand Trump I can't stand Trump
and now they're like actually
I kind of I kind of really wish I had
that that's some interesting stuff now
it's really interesting and it's it's a
it's a change imagine you have to raise
the price of every hair that you every
head that you cut and then that eats
into your gas money gas money gas money
is up inflation is up and then less if
fewer people come get their hair cut
because it's more expensive and now
they're looking around they're like just
get me back to the way it was when
President Trump was here yeah well it's
also wild to see how quickly this
dropped the figures I'm having here
showed that black people black men voted
for Obama at a rate about 95 by the time
it was on to Hillary Clinton it was 82
percent I gotta say the fact that
firstly the fact that fewer black men
voted for Biden than Hillary what what
appeal I could sort of understand like
Biden was with the Obama campaign so
there's an identity politics angle there
and but they do tend to vote Democrat
for sure
like who who genuinely feels that
Hillary Clinton cares about the black
community it's shocking me that anyone
in America does well because she doesn't
and quite frankly neither does Joe Biden
but at the time of over Hillary was a
vote against Trump and I I yeah I get
that it's it's still it's still shocking
me that that many blocks the time before
they knew better yeah yeah but it's also
shocking to me that like Joe Biden got
even less of the black malvelt than
Hillary did
yeah I think they're scared I mean you
could probably speak to this but there
is a disenfranchisement from a lot of
different groups but with black men with
a Democratic party because it has failed
them on so many levels exactly exactly
and it's always the economy and I was
talking to this is really funny actually
I was talking to a buddy Iman he's from
Atlanta and he is absolutely going to
vote for president Trump here in 2024
and he said it'll be the first time I've
a republican but I voted for Trump he
started a company he's doing well he
just started making money he was the
first person to go to college in his
family he's beginning to make some
generational wealth and he told me he
goes bruh
I just got this money and you want to
tax that 50 and I'm just now getting
those because you lost me at I'm going
to raise ta I'm going to raise
[Laughter]
Mal I'm out and so you're looking at
kind of this next generation of people
that are like yeah this just isn't
working out for me like it like it had
been in the past or like I was told it
was supposed to work out and again this
is why you don't ever give Your
Allegiance as a body to any one thing or
to any one group ever when I talk to a
lot of my black friends as well they
don't care about Republican or Democrat
they don't they don't care anymore is
this is actually like not even a thing
what they want is government to work for
them and their best interest and they
don't want to feel like they're just
being overlooked and thrown to the side
and the rising tide raises all boats and
they want to be treated just like
everybody else and to be better off
before but better off now than they were
before well I just can't understand this
you know being from Chicago having a
hundred years of democrat rules right
and problem after problem after problem
nothing ever getting solved I have to
wonder if what's actually happening is
that people who get who people who grew
up in Chicago eventually just give up on
the political system or leave and then
the young people who are there are like
it'll change when I'm old enough and I
can vote and it doesn't they keep voting
for the same policies the same people
I'm wondering at what point in the
United States does the black community
say hey wait a minute the Democrats
actually haven't done anything for us
so they've also gotten away with
painting the Republican party as being
racist yeah and then someone like me
comes around decides to run for Congress
let's talk about my district back in
Houston Texas I live in a district that
President Trump would have won by 23
points I ended up winning by 30 points
in the Republican primary I beat out
nine white guys in the general election
I beat out a white guy by 30 points
Trump plus 20 District I'll perform the
president I'd like to say that every now
and again by a little vet uh and it's a
white majority District in the
Republican primary 75 percent of the
voters were white and they voted for me
overwhelmingly and why because I was the
best candidate that's it that's
literally what our party is I get to
wake up every day and live Martin Luther
King's dream I'm literally being judged
by the content of my character not by
the color of my skin so people like me
come around and we look around I'm just
like actually I'm just here because I
just want to better America I don't even
view myself as black or African-American
first first of all I'm an American I'm a
combat veteran I am a father I am a West
Point graduate I'm an Ivy League
graduate and we can go all the way down
the line before I get to Black I'm a
cool guy right I try to be I'm a father
I'm all these things and I like the idea
of our party not playing identity
politics anymore and then realizing that
you see people like me you see people
like Byron Donald you see people like
Senator Scott we are all winning in
white majority areas by the way people
so you can't call us racist anymore
Obama won twice
a white supremacist country that had a
black president weird two times twice
other country in the entire world would
elect a minority to be the head of their
country twice by wait wait by beating a
Vietnam war hero yeah and the clintons
and Mitt Romney who's like the liliest
like whitest dude ever he's the head of
the Mormons
it gets no wider than that you know what
I mean do you get pushy for being a
Republican all the time all the time
what do you say or like your kids ever I
guess they're pretty young but I love it
yeah I love it if you'll see like the
conflict oh I love it because I'm
antithetical to the to the person that
I'm supposed to be yeah they look at
somebody like me they automatically
assume that I'm a Democrat and they
don't ask any questions about my
background or anything like that and
then if you actually heard my background
you knew where I came from you come from
military family grew up in a church you
find out very quickly why would this guy
be a Democrat no exactly
so but this is
this is a very real thing right so I
lived in I live in Georgia I've lived in
Georgia about the past eight years now
the the area that I'm in has a high
black population and this could just be
because most of the friends I make are
through my Social Circle at church but
they're not socially liberal people by
any means and if you look at the polling
data especially on gay and trans issues
black people are far more conservative
than white people
the black community oftentimes has
allowed the benevolent white liberal
to convince them that they have more in
common than they think when in actuality
they have nothing in common
now what they'll tell the black
community is black lives matter and
we're we're here for you and we're here
to give give people handouts and give
you stuff that's what they say all the
time but by black lives matter the only
thing they they do is change their
Facebook profile picture to Black a
black Square they don't do anything
they've never done anything for black
people they don't even have black
friends would you think that some of
their policies
right person goes I have black friends
the reason they get mad at that isn't
because that's not an argument Against
Racism but it's not true for them none
of them know any black people they
actually don't 95 94 95 crime Bill Joe
Biden
disproportionately put black people
black men specifically in prison for
cocaine versus crack wine because
cocaine was the more affluent White Drug
crack was not and you at
you know I said this to the hearing oh
my gosh that's brutal shout out to
Notorious BIG he famously said when
talking about the only way to get out
the hood he goes either you're slinging
crack rock or you got a wicked jump shot
Hunter Biden has no jump shot
but he be slaying crack rock if you know
oh man and and so Hunter and so Joe
Biden is responsible for that
legislation that disproportionately
locked up black people and yet he is now
the president for the for for the group
of people that black people
overwhelmingly vote for that's a joke to
me I'll I'll phrase something very
somewhat unfairly but are you helping a
child when the child screams that they
want more ice cream are you helping them
by giving them ice cream or are you
helping them by having them go out
exercise eyes yeah do some push-ups with
you look
kids are gonna be like I don't want to
eat my vegetables that's right and you
say you got to eat your vegetables
because we need it for you it's good for
you and I feel like what ends up
happening often with the Republicans
versus the Democrats is the Democrats
will offer you the ice cream with extra
fudge and the Republicans will offer
reparations exactly but they never
actually do it but they can't do it they
dangle it right and the Republicans say
something like we're going to give you
the ability to work hard so you can
fulfill your dreams and then all of
these voters are not singling on any
rights I mean there's all of the people
who vote Democrat are just like I don't
want to work I'm we're seeing polls now
gen Z doesn't want to work crazy it's
well I'm not surprised but I don't
understand what else you do with your
life yes I want to make one point you
said that what Republicans say you know
the Democrats say we're going to give
you free stuff and the Republicans say
we're gonna give you good policy so you
can work hard and live out your dreams
it tends to be more like the Democrats
going we're going to give you free stuff
and the Republicans going we're going to
passcode
exactly yeah I mean it's it's like what
we're saying is our like what we're
saying is already more boring in a sense
even though it's more reasonable and
then we say it in a boring way on top of
it to be fair they do also have people
like Nancy
pelosiers
and Schumer right and they're they're
not very you know charismatic at all but
neither is Mitch McConnell but yeah no
what I tend to see is it's like Mom
versus Dad it's Dad being like look you
gotta mow the lawn life's not fair yes
but it builds character it makes you
stronger makes you more capable and then
the Democrats of the mountain being like
us to get an ice cream that's it yep
that's it but well to be fair the mom
never shows up with the ice cream that's
exactly right she just says and that's
exactly you know it kind of kind of back
to the argument they know that they are
hemorrhaging black male voters and so
now what's what's the push now more free
stuff
by giving them free stuff and now I
think we're getting to the point to
where we're not falling for it anymore
like I don't I don't believe you you're
exactly right you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna promise US ice cream and
then you're not gonna deliver it the
reparations thing comes around every
every four years every four years well
this is this is what they're doing while
they're panicking
the level of pandering
it's like Pelosi had the scarf I wanted
Pelosi and all the Democrats were
kneeling and they had those like African
scarves on it it was ridiculous okay
come on come on now
I think that Democrats are running out
of free stuff to offer the outweigh the
the cons right like their voters can see
that there's there is nothing in these
promises even if you get a mod a small
amount of money or some kind of benefit
ultimately your community is still
hurting and this is true for a lot of
people across the US that's correct uh I
mean the example we always get is uh the
effect social welfare has had on the
black family which has been horrible
it's been awesome all Democrat policies
by the way yeah because they hate the
family it's not just the black family
they hate all families they want you to
be dependent on the government so I'm
here right now my family I talk to my
family we all go to West Point we all
served our country why is that I had two
parents my parents did not play games my
parents made sure that we went to church
they cared about where we went to school
by the way this isn't like about black
or white people this is about like you
show me any individual that grew up in
the house like I grew up in regardless
of of the color of their skin
functioning nuclear family yes and well
and this is huge right because they
won't let through that down by the way
they want to destroy them of course oh
they've wanted to I mean from the get-go
right because on some level their values
are satanic they hate the family they
hate anything that requires love or any
level of goodness I don't think they
conceive of it that way logically but
family bothers them and when you look at
the data the white family is
unfortunately very much catching up to
those rates of illegitimacy uh the the
rates are increasing everywhere now with
out of wedlock births and fatherless
homes and one thing not a lot of people
consider is that with the black family
falling apart and then the white family
following
this is often linked to social welfare
policies and that played a role but the
Brookings Institute released a pretty
interesting analysis where they were
attributing it to abortion and Roe v
Wade and the removal of the social
expectation that pregnancy meant you
were going to have a child and that the
man should be there to take care of the
child interesting that's correct yeah I
mean also in more democratic policies
but also
all fathomably evil Democratic policy
like yes let's kill babies then Sheamus
just goes yeah so so and then there's
again the disproportionate impact that
it has on a black community one in three
abortions are at the hands of a black
woman one in three and yet we are 13 of
the population now look I don't care if
you're a pro-life or pro-choice you
cannot be satisfied with the
disproportionate amount of a group of
people not existing on this Earth
because we have a culture that allows
that to happen that's a problem and
Democrats won't talk about that New York
City that black babies more likely to be
aborted there are more in New York City
there are more aborted black babies than
born in Margaret Sanger was clear about
why she was starting Planned Parenthood
by the way very quickly yeah do you ever
see the commercial Lena Dunham was in
and she's like yeah yeah there's some
sketchy history
it's like what it's like saying like
Nazi Germany had some sketchy stuff
going like she was an opening Genesis
she was an open eugenicist who wanted to
eliminate what she saw as lesser races
yes
my single child-free life she obviously
cares about back to your point too about
how you say things and how you make
arguments as well and why the Democrats
are very good at this yeah so we
overturned Roe v Wade the only thing
that happened over turning Roe v Wade in
the Dobbs case was that we returned the
issue back to the individual states we
live in a constitutional republic that's
how this whole thing works all we did
that's all we did we didn't ban anything
what did the Democrats do no that's
that's a mouthful Republicans we live in
a constitutional republic and the only
thing that we did was return the rights
passes which is true what did they say
women's rights you hate women well you
see what doug they Randall that and they
won on that and Republicans that's not
true I think it's crazy that uh I don't
want you to have to murder your child is
hating them well also and Republicans
retreated right because they just
assumed people weren't going to be
willing to side with them on the
pro-life message so instead of hitting
the messaging as hard as they possibly
could to be persuasive they tried to
hide from the fact that Roe was
overturned it's like you guys just did
the one effective thing I've seen
Republicans do in 20 years and you're
not going to bring that up when you're
running for office like we've had a
massive Victory and you're not going to
talk about that because you're scared
some people won't like it that was a
massive blunder in mind well I thought
it was where Donald Trump struggled a
little bit and I agreeable with CNN
because they were trying to push him
would you uh you know federally ban
abortion whatever he should have just
said it's a state's issue we saw that no
like just hit that point over and over
again it's a state's rights issues what
they said was based yes I will he's not
my phone but you know what I mean
so when Trump was asked about by Megan
Kelly about calling women fat pigs he
says
he didn't run away from it he owned it
yeah Republicans should be like yeah
actually we did support president Trump
we are glad to see the states now have
the right to pass legislation exactly
and you may notice that in many of the
blue States they've been more accepting
and uh permissive of abortion and in red
states where the majority of the people
that's called democracy isn't it if you
don't like it you can vote with your
feet and you live in a different state
that's more palatable to your beliefs
but you you own it and you explain to
people why when the Republicans hide
from it it creates the impression that
it was the wrong thing to do and they're
ashamed of it well I think we have to
own it in a much different way I hear
what you're saying about the fact the
Democrats are going this is about
women's rights the Republicans should be
saying this is about children's rights
or babies rights or not allowing babies
to die but instead because Republic
Democrats aren't saying well Federal
power is being challenged so for the
answer to be will states have right
rights now is the wrong response they're
going at this from the angle of making
it a very emotional issue and they
should they should because it is
emotional and that's how you persuade
people boom but Republicans won't
Republicans are like let's have a
conversation about the legal precedent
that allowed for this to occur and why
you should be okay with it come on the
average person doesn't care do you think
that there's an effective way for
Republicans to argue this issue
emotionally I feel like so awesome yes I
feel like it's like the easiest one to
argue babies are dying yeah but they'll
say well it's not a baby it's not real
don't argue a fetus argue a baby yes so
I recognize that but I feel like any
moderate who leans left or Progressive
would say like you guys are being crazy
no no Republicans are just bad at what
they do yeah I told the story before but
you know Bears repeating for our
Congressman Frontier a friend of mine
who's a liberal in New York City not
very politically active but just kind of
ignore me when when Democrats were
voting on the uh restrictionless
abortion I think we it was Colorado but
there was also a Democrat Bill federally
that would allow abortion at any stage
of pregnancy if there was a medical
issue and when I brought this up and
said
there's a whole lot we can get into is
pertaining to the medical issue uh point
but it does allow for terminating the
life of a baby that can survive on its
own and he said that's not true they
would never do that and I grabbed my
phone and I pulled it up I said read
that line and he reads and he goes
something's not right something this
that can't be correct and I said well
look whether you think I'm right or
wrong let me ask you do you think that a
woman let's say let's say she can't have
the baby should they like find a way to
deliver that baby and remove it let it
live or should they just kill him he's
like well yeah they should find any way
they can have the baby live but I think
they're saying that like if the woman
can't carry the baby anymore she can
have an abortion because of a medical
issue and I said
so in the circumstance where the baby
can survive and the pregnancy can be
terminated and the mother saved why kill
the baby and then he was just like I I
don't believe that there's something's
wrong
and so the point is regular people need
to hear that yeah that's the position
from where Republicans should be arguing
saying like look when Donald Trump was
asked about banning abortion he gave a
brilliant answer he says it depends on
where the deal is some people think six
weeks some people think eight weeks
we'll have to see what the deal is the
compromise he is a deal maker yeah and I
think that's the American people need to
be told it's we're not talking about
forcing women to give birth or whatever
that weird nonsense line is it doesn't
really make sense anyway makes no sense
there is a baby the baby is in the woman
now let's try and protect the rights of
the woman and the child if the child can
survive on its own I ask you this why
would we permit it to be killed perfect
so and I'll add this obviously everyone
knows everyone here knows my stance on
abortion the audience does completely
against it I think the Republican party
needs to be completely against it that
said when you look at the way the
parties operate as they currently stand
the Republican position is anywhere
ranging from no abortion should ever be
allowed which base that's the correct
take two there should be some
restrictions on abortion the Democratic
position is there should be zero
restrictions on abortion that is the
actual Democratic party and that's
insane completely I mean that is your
average person absolutely that's insane
in Colorado up to birth yes which which
means based on that definition your
average person is far more in line with
the Republican approach here and and I'm
a good example of that and we've had a
couple different leftists on this show
and the funny thing about the
conversation is that they know they
can't answer it without looking bad so
they try to wiggle around the answer but
I say do you think a woman should be
able to terminate a viable baby to kill
it to abort it at nine months and they
go well I mean you got understand we're
talking about no no no no simple
question and they go yes she said it's
her body I'm like there it is that's
crazy it is that's that's crazy if the
baby has to come out of the woman it's
there why kill it in the process right
because that's the whole point perhaps
yeah it's the whole point if it wasn't a
human they wouldn't be killing it and
this is the problem I have because I I
come from a Libertarian uh perspective
on this pertaining to government rights
and limitations right and recognize
we've got human two human lives we're
dealing with the left seems to just say
whatever they want to say so they can
get the right to kill the baby with no
accountability for the other life right
zero I'm reminded of uh Governor
Billingsley of Washington he sent this
letter to Idaho's Governor Brad little
saying uh I'm asking you to veto your
abortion trafficking law and this was uh
Littles the law on like if you transport
a minor out of state for an abortion
without telling your parents you are in
trouble uh he was like because if the
women of Washington traveled to your
state and have to get an abortion you
will persecute them it's like yes why
would they travel across the border to
that when Washington is a pro-abortion
state but instead it's like because you
might affect my government your
government must change to fit my rules I
don't see any Republican state doing
that instead they're locking down their
state saying we do not allow abortion
here are here are the limited exceptions
instead it's left State saying we are
under attack I wanna I wanna talk about
some good news some very good news this
is a story from Fox Business Target
loses 9 billion dollars amid Pride
merchandising controversy Target stock
is experiencing its worst six day
stretch since the six days ending May
25th and not only that Bud Lights
anheuser-busch's stock hasn't they've
wiped out all of their gains from the
year so far they're now down for the
year fantastic this is the Bud Light
effect it was the Catalyst Bud Light was
the easiest thing to boycott for anybody
and they did near 30 percent sales
dropped now Target is scared saying uh
oh we don't want to end up like Bud
Light the fear now is this social social
effect where
the people who held on to their
Anheuser-Busch stock because they were
assured by the media don't worry these
things will fizzle out they've lost a
lot of money a lot I think it's like 12
or 13 percent now if you're hearing this
so you experienced that a month ago
you're like I got my Anheuser Bush stock
at 60 65 bucks I'm not worried about it
now it's at you know 50 something I
don't know where it's at you're going
okay I just lost a ton of money this I
can't let this happen again so people
are probably gonna start selling off
more and more Anheuser-Busch stock
because the price is going down it's
become a cell not a whole not a buy
Target then becomes the subject of
controversy if you just lost a ton of
money on Anheuser-Busch stock and you're
sitting there seeing the news I'm
assuming a lot of these people say nope
I am selling right now I don't need to
hold on to Target I could hold on to any
other stock I'll buy Apple I'll buy
Tesla I'm moving my money boom stock
starts dropping then it creates a
Cascade effect where other people go
they call it their their you know broker
or they call up their uh wealth
management manager or whatever and say
why why is why is my portfolio going
down and say oh well Target just
suffered a major drop off we'll sell
sell why are we in it why are we in
Target right now how many people are now
not it's it's not even an impact of the
boycott it's an impact of
if there is fear in the in the public
that a stock will drop due to boycott
that will be a self-fulfilling prophecy
the Bud Light effect if you go woke your
stock will drop people are going to
start selling off and if you don't you
will be the one holding the empty bag
and that's the sentiment where people go
not going to be me with a potato I'm
there's there's a billion other stocks
to buy nobody cares about Target Target
stock so while it's not so easy to
boycott a big box store like Target if
it's the only one in your neighborhood
it's really easy to buy a different
stock to put your money very easy very
easy that's what I think we're seeing
that's what I think what we may we may
be seeing that now and Target's 100
reinforcing what you're saying they are
just as Panic they're quietly moving
things off their web website we'll see
these reports of some stores being told
to relocate their merchandise uh they
had that collaboration with uh I think
it's called uh abharlin it's the UK he
says he's not a he says he's not a
Satanist by the way but it's this guy
named Eric Carnell the shirt yeah he
says he's not he just makes some fun
Satanist merchandise
Aaron's identifying designer
and so so I wrote this story about
Target a couple days ago I was checking
out some of this person's merchandising
uh and I noticed that Eric Carnell's
stuff today has been moved off the
Target website this person has also
closed his Etsy and his storefront wow
uh and has pulled posts from social
media that were like basically anti-cis
they had like lighters that said burn
the CIS dumb down CIS super cool a
homophobic headrest and it's a
guillotine and in the if you can find
this stuff on Twitter sell people people
grab the screenshots uh all of these
comment surveys click we need to destroy
this system it's not enough to just ask
or be accepted we have to dismantle
what's there very radical kind of
semi-calls for violence and it's it's a
really interesting time where Target
panicked and so this person panicked and
you can see the effect now now he's
destroying Target right not the whole
system I I don't know I mean in some
ways he's a catalyst well and then
Reuters ran this article that was like
uh this UK designer that clever Target
is seeing a rise in say sales and that's
why he closed his website I don't think
that's true I just want to put that out
on air right now
rubbing his stuff to make sure anything
that is deemed controversial or radical
is off now that you might be able to
capitalize on sympathetic leftist
dollars or or stop trying to groom our
children
um
or just don't do that the culture War
elements of this are less important than
a monetary elements of this I I agree
there's going to be
I'm imagining some there's a young
wealth management wealth manager guy
he's managing some portfolios for some
people they get on the phone he goes
look I'm going to recommend against
Target stock uh there's some controversy
going on I don't know a whole lot about
it but it's probably risky let's move
you over to something safer maybe we'll
put you over here somewhere else right
yeah I mean I don't know why I don't
just start shorting these stocks as soon
as these stories break
that is not Financial advice
we're very careful about Not Giving that
advice in years past this type of panic
hasn't been that effective right like we
saw a slow burn after the Cutie stuff on
Netflix people being like I'm leaving
Netflix and they did see some trouble it
wasn't as dramatic as the Bud Light
issue but right now this has really hit
a nerve and to follow so quickly after
that you can see people feeling more
motivated they saw uh their decision to
boycott having a financial impact maybe
they can do it again they can really
feel like they're making a difference I
have a four-year-old daughter I have a
two-year-old daughter and I have a four
month old little boy and my wife was
religiously shopping at Target and if
you're telling me that we're selling
bathing suits that allow you to tuck
tuckable bathing suits to children they
weren't for kids no the children one say
uh thoughtfully made
exactly exactly exactly so it was like
it was like a double entender in that
case right so they were condo in both
but also I don't even want my children
walking past that stuff amen right
that's this number one so you worked
about ice cream earlier
and uh my kids love ice cream and if I
left it up to them my little daughter
would eat ice cream for breakfast lunch
and dinner so why in God's name would I
allow my child to select her gender at
four five six seven years old before
she's even an adult I don't like the
idea of even even walking our children
in front of this in my anti-trans no
when you're an adult you can do whatever
you want in this country as long as
you're not hurting other people as long
as you're not hurting anybody else and
the fact is my job as United States
Congressman to keep the federal
government actually out of your life
that's that's what I'm trying to do more
than anything else but for children this
is ridiculous yeah I think real quick I
think what we may be seeing with Target
is that it's not actually a boycott from
conservatives I think this reaction was
so rapid that regular people walked in
and had a very negative reaction like
why is this in front of my kids and
these are not political but so this is
75-25 issue in this country three so
when it's a 75-25 issue that means this
is not a partisan issue this is
literally people being like I might be
liberal but this is insane yeah well the
first time I heard about this was on an
Instagram reels of you know a leftist
you know influencer saying basically
like why are they pandering to us with
this weird Pride stuff they're making
fun of the fact that there's like a
queer all year calendar like yeah nobody
wants nobody wants that why did Target
do this they only hurt themselves ESG
baby no they're they're trying to Virtue
signal that's it they want to be true
but the people signaling don't like it
they don't want it well I mean and
that's why they have a shirt that says
live laugh lesbian I don't know what
does that even mean I don't know I don't
understand I was like we're gonna win
we're provocative yeah I guess
they're falling in line with the ESG
stuff if you want funding and financing
ESG is the way to go and then they're
thinking this is what people like the
reason these companies do it is because
they think if this is what's popular
socially this is what's in Hollywood now
that there is a negative impact and
people saw Bud Light this the bug Light
thing is a major shift in culture War
yeah because now these companies are
going no that's controversial and you'll
lose money don't do it exactly like it
used to be the case that what it should
be just drink beer yes right yeah I mean
it used to be the case that getting
political was controversial and now it's
been the case that getting political
isn't controversial as long as it's a
left-wing opinion but the left has gone
so far that they're getting back to the
point where leftism is once again
beginning to be seen as controversial
thank goodness thank goodness
there's a good news this is uh this is a
very optimistic moment for everybody I
think I think we're gonna start seeing
more of these stock drop-offs we saw
with Netflix something similar maybe a
precursor to this when they lost
something like two or two million how
many how many subscribers they lose it
millions of subscribers or something
like that and we don't know exactly why
but a lot of people think it may be
because of the cuties thing because of
big mouth and these other shows that
they're like we don't we don't want to
pay for this I think Disney is now
experiencing a neighbor
user drop off and uh
yeah I I think get well go broke is
starting to become more and more
starting to catch but I think it's
because the left has just gone too far
exactly I think you're right it's not a
conservative issue or it's not it's not
political because when you lose that
many subscribers it they all are
conservatives that are that are that are
subscribed it's actually people that are
parents that are looking at something
and they think to themselves you know I
can't explain to you what what perverted
is but I know it when I see it yeah and
that's what it is and any parent who
cares about their kids that they're
going to protect their their kids from
that exactly the parents are gonna well
like technically uh that doesn't have to
be inherently sexual so we can try to
separate it out yeah I don't know I
don't want this near my kid I think I
think I think it's much much simpler
than that yeah I think the parent turns
on Netflix and is clicking through and
goes
I don't I don't think we should have
this on the TV uh honey because if we
don't want the kids watching it okay
well I'll just cancel but they don't
even think that much about it for the
average person life is much simpler than
those of us who are entrenched in
cultures for sure for sure they walk
into Target and they go oh my god let's
go somewhere else
exactly what you're talking about they
don't they look at it now some level of
a register I don't want to have to have
this conversation with my kids it's not
even at the Forefront of the range just
like a repulse and now let's just
separate from it they don't want to be
okay I'm here right now
we're glad you're here too man this is
so good to hear because because I I'm
constantly surrounded by by I think
highly informed people we always get
into these you know these pragmatic
conversations and we go down these
rabbit holes and I think sometimes we
can take a step back in here I I think
you're right I think it is much more
people yeah well because look when I
heard about Target losing all this money
wow I'm like there's no way
conservatives organized a boycott this
effective this quickly no that's
impossible exactly exactly
moronic there is no way when they said
that there were confrontations I was
like if there were confrontations it was
not because Matt Walsh got on his show
and said we're gonna boycott life it's
because a regular person with his
four-year-old daughter walked in and
went oh my my God and I don't Daddy
what's a lesbian what where did you see
that it said live laugh lesbian he's
like that's not even Dramatical
maybe a little bit older than four I
don't know what year a lot of these kids
are learning to read but they probably I
don't know if they can read the word
lesbian or even notice it yeah but the
parents probably see these things right
when they walk in and say I don't want
my kid I'm not going to explain to my
four-year-old what these things are
that's a good point we don't have like
these are sexual subjects yes the left
denies but they literally are LGBT is a
reference well LGB is a reference to who
you enjoy engaging in adult activities
with and then they added tea to it which
is transgender which doesn't necessarily
relate to the others that's why there's
been a controversy there but if you're
putting something up right in the front
display being like celebrate who you
have sex with you are now having to
explain to Children what this means and
why and you're like my kids aren't ready
for the birds and the bees talk let
alone LGBT birds and the bees talk you
walk into Target normally what do you
see you see the Easter Bunny you see
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups you see
sweaters Santa Claus Christmas stuff
yeah
dude the way it's going they'll be like
trying to get tell them about like
sodomy and then when you want to talk
about the birds and the bees they're
like they're too young for that like
they can't have this conversation they
they there was uh in these schools when
Ron DeSantis started uh Banning these
these uh pornographic books perverted
like they're they're over they're Kink
books
these things are not sexual it's very
important right it's fetish porn they're
uh uh Nikki freed called it butt plug
porn mocking Ron DeSantis not realizing
she was proving his point exactly when I
showed this to a lefty friend of mine he
says it's sex ed I said no it's not this
is kink Kink education for children that
that's ridiculous if you think that
is sex ed I don't even want to know what
you think sex is all right okay well
when you take a light bulb and then you
uh eat it up yeah
the the idea is not how human beings
function this is not how this is not how
man's body was built to function so now
we understand why homeschooling's on the
rack
I just got to say this when we make fun
of people who go to the hospital with
foreign objects lodged in their rectums
it's because you can't do that but
people develop paraphilias and fetishes
where they do things to their bodies
that are damaging yes we don't want to
make people develop behaviors that are
harmful to them and we want to protect
children from these things why would a
school teach a child about putting
foreign objects into their anus is
beyond me but I'm glad Rada Santa said f
that and got rid of it ooh but it's not
Beyond you you know why they're doing it
we know why they're doing it because
they want kids
they're groomers that's it because
they'll say uh Target already came out
on the pride issue a long time ago they
sell like Mr and Mr wedding cards like
they're fine it's this year's specific
push for the transgender gender too far
issue well that is uh I think really
enraging people or maybe bringing
attention into an aspect of all of this
that people are firmly against right
well and this is something conservatives
have to remember when we message this
okay the conversation is not over why do
kids need to see this we know they don't
the question is why do you need kids to
see this why do you need to show this
disgusting fetish porn to Children
what's wrong with you the conversation
has to be about the person who's trying
to show this stuff to kids Democrat
Nikki Freedom Florida called the
material that got banned butt plug porn
exactly because she was making fun of
Rhonda Santos and it was like thank you
for proving the whole point yep that
shouldn't be for children not for kids
he was saying this is school and she's
like can you believe me shared this on
Twitter in front of adults it's like
it's being shown to children in schools
you lunatic Let's uh let's jump to the
next level of where wokeness gets you
you guys ready for this one this is from
comptroller.nyc.gov this is not a news
article it's an official government
Source saying New York City banking
commission votes to approve 26
depository banks for two years limits
new deposits at Capital One and Key Bank
now why is it that they're restricting
deposits at Capital One Bank let me tell
you they say
following the first ever public hearing
held by the New York City banking
commission today all three members voted
to limit deposits at Capital One in Key
Bank after the banks failed to submit
required plans demonstrating their
efforts to root out discrimination
honestly that's a fair response I think
that's what had to happen I yeah I'm
actually the left on this one I actually
answered no but I really am I I really
am they're gonna gut the major Banks
because they they okay
no that's not what I just think yeah
[Applause]
I think I don't know how racism is going
to end if they don't do this if if if
this is the if they're they're going to
consume each other and and the big you
know for it
when when the Federal Reserve announced
they were getting woke I was like oh no
wait don't don't do that yeah don't
self-implode right exactly but in all
seriousness this is this is this is
scary stuff look I just don't trust a
bank that doesn't waive rainbow flag and
say we are openly anti-racist hashtag
BLM it's not enough to be not racist you
have to be on board with our leftist
programs yeah we label anti-racism like
I just don't know how you could trust a
bank that isn't doing that how have they
demonstrated confidence if we're talking
about social justice maybe they could
give out copies of anti-racist baby to
all new customers I see now that I think
I'd be if they're not to be to be honest
if they're not giving genderqueer out to
every customer I just don't know how
they could be a reliable Bank
anti-racist baby is a better book to
give do you think so yeah and the Race's
baby's funnier to say so the Press
funnier to say the press release is
saying that uh they hear testimony from
Muslim New Yorkers who've experienced
discrimination in the process of open
air closing counts and then also climate
Advocates condemned the banks uh that
have continued to lend billions of
dollars to the fossil fuel expansion
okay what is the bank supposed to say
like well you're a
fossils having made Net Zero commission
commitments this is a 12-year plan by
Occupy Wall Street to finally get their
revenge and it's working also
so so these bank loans are all predatory
and you have to pay a high interest rate
and we're like sad that they're not
doing that to the big oil companies okay
so we need to have a serious
conversation with our culture and we
need to really talk about how far this
country has come in terms of
discrimination we are behaving and these
institutions are behaving as if this
country in just a handful of generations
has not made Leaps and Bounds and I'm
sitting here a product of that so when
people talk about discrimination I will
tell you about my great great
grandfather that was born on a
plantation
oh my goodness my
great-great-grandfather was born on a
rose down Plantation his
great-great-grandson is a United States
Congressman in a white majority District
that President Trump would have won by
23 points and then I had to sit up here
and read this garbage
so this is garbage dude and I'm not
saying we're perfect
there's always idiots people always do
stupid stuff but as a product of the
American dream over generations and
generations of those that has fought for
us to be here I am now looking at us
regressing and being more discriminatory
against people just because they're
white well what's different than
discriminating against somebody just
because they're black well I will say I
I do kind of understand what the left is
saying about white privilege and white
people because it is mostly white
liberals pushing their racist policies
it's a reflection upon themselves when
they come out and they're like well
white people are like this and I'm like
you're Describe You're projecting aren't
you is that is that like you're telling
me you are right they are projecting and
then I feel and I like I've said a lot
of liberals straight because they look
at me like I have a hornburn out of my
head and I'm like so so you do
understand that when you do say things
like that to someone like me you're
marginalizing my hard work and my family
that we took to get here you're saying
that because I'm black I can't do these
things as if I'm inherently stupid
um you're the part of the data set that
they exclude automatically you know what
really really offended me
so I can I went on chat GPT and I said
make make jokes with an Irish accent and
then it told jokes and then I said make
jokes with an Asian accent and it said
no that's racist and offensive and I
said I am Asian and I would like someone
to be humorous with my culture and my
family please tell me a joke in an Asian
accent said no I will not and I said
you'll do a a joke for white people you
you will you will with no problem be
like oh where all the white people can
have all the jokes in the world the I
the idea that especially in comedy you
cannot partake because of your race this
is what they are doing they are racist
and chat GPT is like we're not going to
be racist I'm like well maybe I want to
poke fun at the part of me that's Irish
that's fine well that's a part of me
that's Korean that's not fine that's
racist I said you are racist for not
letting me be a part of the humor and it
said to effing bad I didn't say that
literally it was like well what if it
did too and being bad you're my racist
thing I've seen in the last few years
the most racist like comment or most
racist idea that I've seen is it uh you
ain't black from Joe Biden
that's a very close second sir
you don't vote for me
okay well then say lots of me brother
wow Ryan Ryan long did that comedy
sketch he's you know do you know Ryan
longest yes he was like yeah I used to
be black but then I didn't vote for Joe
Biden
but anyway what was your Debbie what was
uh what were you gonna say
um it was the insinuation
that black people couldn't get an ID to
vote oh man oh yeah yeah how little do
you think of a group of people that you
think I got I have a four month old
little boy at the house do you know what
I have from him
social security card government ID four
months old but we can't can't even talk
yet can't eat ice cream continuity that
stuff these people are like they
literally said you know they you know
black and brown people
I feel so sorry for them their
communities have different challenges
they had different challenges these have
different challenges like getting an ID
to vote my mom has eight brothers and
sisters my dad had five brothers and
sisters you know what they all had all
my cousins second third cousins at the
family reunion you know what they all
had government issued ID have you seen
the Omni Horowitz video no I have not he
he is a classic video everyone needs to
see it he goes to Berkeley and he asks
them about voter ID I have seen this
they say it's racist he says why is it
because they can't connect to black
people they're all just like my favorite
thing is when he he likes ghost is one
black guy and he's like excuse me sir
this may seem like a weird question but
do you know where the DMV is and he goes
oh yeah it's right over on 25th
it was such a stupid question he thought
Ami was asking for directions dude not
like do you literally nowhere of course
he knows where it is I actually don't
know what they think black people have
to go through to get an ID I don't know
what they think the journey is like for
a black person trying to get an ID did
you treat like it's the middle passage
they act like it's really not I promise
it's like you have to go to Mordor and
throw your ring in a Mountain Dew
did you see the video the Nuance bro on
Twitter had a Twitter space with this uh
young activist from gen Z for change a
young uh I think he's a young black kid
and he said every year 30 of the black
population is shot and killed by police
and then he was like What if there would
be no black people in three years no
that's not true
the kid goes the kid goes is 15 to 20
Fair
dude but but in reference to the IDS
these people are being told this stuff
yeah I think I think for me you know I
can say it 50 billion times for
everybody who doesn't already know I'm
on the south side of Chicago so I'm in a
very mixed area with a bunch of people
and I'm like oh I'm sitting here
listening to this stuff where they say
black people can't get ideas I'm like
what are you talking about all of my
friends had IDs what are you even
talking about I went to the D we all
went to the DMV and we were 16 got ideas
and got jobs but that's a weird thing
too this is another one of these
AstroTurf things where I never ever
heard a black person complain about not
being able to get an ID and then white
liberals started jumping in and saying
black people can't get ideas there's
something that we never heard from the
black community once yeah I think it's
part of the idea that you rise the
expectations that are given to you right
so if we have we're on the same page if
I think if you have low expectations for
people why would they exceed them right
if especially if they internalize these
low expectations and this isn't a racing
it's for everybody if you think you're
going nowhere you're never gonna have a
job you might as well be on drugs that's
what you're going to do a race by the
way and nothing to do with race it's
just expectation and by the way and it
is a poverty issue I think this country
literally is beyond race this is a it's
a poor people problem issue that we need
to have a conversation about and then
how do we rent poverty in general across
all Races that's the point this is what
I ask my Lefty friends in Chicago I say
when they tell me that they're in favor
of reparations or affirmative action
stuff I said okay so you know in my
neighborhood where it's fairly mixed
what do you think would happen if one
day the government handed out 10 grand
to only the black people yeah I mean you
are creating racial tensions now all the
the slack jawed white trash people salt
of the earth Working Class People Who
struggle every day they're looking at
all this brand new stuff and listen
crime is not an issue of race an issue
of poverty I've witnessed it at least in
my neighborhood firsthand you're right
you know you know what I believe would
happen if they gave reparations only the
black families where I grew up they
would be all the target the target of
robbery yeah but guess what then the
Democrats can go see racism that's it
yeah yep no it's a very failed and
you're right but but I asked my friends
I say why does it make sense that the
white family that lives in the exact
same neighborhood in the exact same
circumstances should be left behind
shouldn't we just say those of you who
are impoverished we will seek to help
that's the point and that's what we've
been doing though right I mean the war
on poverty has been an unmitigated
failure we already had the federal
government try to give money
disproportionately to the
African-American Community from the
taxpayer base right we saw that happen
and it hasn't lifted them out out of
poverty create a welfare state we
created a massive welfare state and we
made their circumstances far worse
how much money yeah the welfare program
unit should be strengthening the family
amen
the government program should be how can
we improve your family yeah you know how
how can we how can we encourage people
who are married to stay married how can
we encourage young people who are this
is so bizarre they want every kid in
every school to explore every disgusting
bizarre sexual lifestyle choice and
perversion but they're unwilling to have
a conversation with them about finding
the right person to marry ensuring that
you have the same values not having sex
with that person so you don't become
blinded by the hormones and end up
marrying the wrong person and then
bringing children into the world with
someone you're not going to stay with
that's never the conversation when we're
talking about educating children to be
adults who have to operate in the world
and contend with the sexual nature of
reality it's always let's show them
disgusting perverted fetish porn not
let's show them how they can build
strong families have you met Sheamus
[Laughter]
got really mad
but it makes me incredibly angry they
think oh no we just want them to be
prepared for the future okay then show
them how to start a family and how to
build relationships that are healthy so
it doesn't end up with there being
broken homes everywhere I got I got a
lot of flack from the left when I said
that a child is more likely to learn
about gay sex than they are about
bouncing a checkbook or or opening a
bank account you're correct some some
and then they're just like oh Darian I'm
like dude our schools do not teach
Finance at all and you know if they
don't get at school if the parents
aren't either yep there's no way how
would you learn it I think uh personal
finance should be a core class I get
having a sex ed class in basic
biological these are the organs of what
they do of course I think it should stop
there right and I think to your point so
much of what we teach kids is to divorce
uh responsibility from from the action
right so with the rise of birth control
and with uh widespread abortion it's
when you choose to have sex it's
completely for pleasure and you should
always believe that there is no risk of
pregnancy and therefore linking yourself
to another human being not just the baby
but this person who has bothered it or
the mother of it for the rest of your
lives we want their we want to teach
people they live in a society without
consequences but if you are not willing
to accept responsibility you can never
turn your life into anything amen and so
what they're doing is they're they're
literally showing
fetish porn of sodomy two children and
their excuses this happens in the real
world you know what else happens in the
real world people get married or they
don't but they have children with
somebody that they don't end up staying
with and then you have a broken home so
here's the question if we're gonna have
sex then if we're gonna have sodomy
education which they're pushing why not
marriage education but why not teach
kids what they need to do to have a
healthy relationship with the opposite
sex and have a lasting marriage because
that's kind of important in a
functioning Society you're right and we
had that but I want to add you know what
else happens in the real world
I don't I don't know like bricklaying
yeah like why why is this where they go
to like well it happens we better show
it this is the thing when something
disgusting happens we need to ensure it
keeps happening by showing it to
Children right by telling them that this
is okay normal acceptable we know what
this is we know this is grooming that's
why it's that's why it's grooming I
think the easiest way to explain why
it's grooming is the excuse of like well
you know this is a part of life so the
kids need to be educated on it's like
dude there are a billion things that
happen in the real world we do not have
in schools you know what else maybe part
of life and and most of them like the
majority of things we don't have in
schools are perfectly safe for kids we
just don't have them there like I
mentioned bricklaying or how about the
mines how about we we show children like
to go mine underground yeah like even
that is safer what if like for every
dollar you spend on this bizarre sex
education you have to spend a thousand
dollars on shop classes or welding or
some kind of Trades something home act
personal finance classes like put the
money that you could be spending on
buying anti-racist baby in to actual
things that children use to better their
lives I just realized this too I mean I
didn't have the schools that I went to
had no shop or home act or anything like
that do they even have those anymore
they're coming back most of them don't
my school had a food science because we
weren't allowed to have homec because it
was too anti-feminists yeah we had yeah
we had food science and it was great I
took that class it was just a bunch of
girls they did all the cooking for me
because they knew I wasn't able to
handle it
with girls
besides was great at my high school
because it was like extra food during
the day right exactly it was extra food
we had an intro to accounting course
that actually the the teacher on his own
elected to say like here's how you do
your taxes here's how you balance a
checkbook like he himself decided this
was part of it he didn't have to teach
that I think that's crazy it was an
elective it was only available to
seniors why could you not teach a
freshman to do that well it's so weird
too right because when they try to force
these things onto kids what their what
their response is usually when you point
out that this is a disgusting horrible
thing that we should not be showing to
Young eyes and then ideally no one would
ever have to see their response is well
I know you don't want people to do this
and I don't either I promise but this is
going to happen so we should instruct
them in it so they know how to do it
safely we don't do that with any other
thing that we don't want people doing we
don't go like well we should show them
how to commit crime safely we should
show them how to be racist safely we
should show them how to be sexist in a
way where they won't lose their career
or something like that because they're
gonna do it anyway well educate people
to not do things but there's there's one
final thing I want to mention here which
is for all the the beloveiating the
engagement about how real world
realities need to be imparted to
children in a way that completely
destroys their innocence okay you know
what happens in the real world
people who have more sexual partners
before they're married are more likely
to get divorced virgins rate in all
surveys is having the highest level of
satisfaction in their marriages people
who choose to stay married instead of
getting divorced after five years in the
majority of cases say they're glad they
stay married but those aren't realities
we can educate kids on we can only show
them non-binary fetish wow I wanna I
wanna bring up the uh
you guys see the uh story from the the
Dodgers they're having the the drag
queen nuns come yeah you know I I saw
that and I thought how is that actually
allowed how is it how are they allowed
to have drag queen nuns because I'm
pretty sure the LA Dodgers would not
legally be allowed to have a Minstrel
show in the field because it violates
civil rights laws and discrimination
laws and the response on the left was
you're a Karen hahaha we can do whatever
you want I thought you cared about free
speech and I'm like oh I'm for free
speech so yeah my question is how do you
justify Banning hate speech and then
literally invite men to mock Christians
yeah this openly and and drastically
it's like it's like one thing for a
community to make a joke about
Christians and we all like it's funny
yeah this is another thing to get a
bunch of men to dress up like demon nun
women and then come in openly just
insulting see that's not the most and
that's not funny
nuns exist in the real world yeah maybe
it may be funny to those who hate
Christians but how how are they allowed
to do it with discriminate I think
Christians should file a discrimination
lawsuit well I think I represent mayor
on the LA Dodgers who has some sort of
Bible quote on his social media profile
should immediately ask to be transferred
off the team I mean I think there's a
lot of people who take action here in
this country hate speech laws are
questionable anyways but they are meant
to protect people if you if you work in
any way at that Stadium or you work in
any way with any of the companies Sue
right now yes absolutely if you if you
worked for a company that allowed that
and imagine this a Muslim guy works for
a company and they bring in a bunch of
drag Muslim imams to dance around going
Hallelujah did you get sued in two
seconds there might be more than a
lawsuit yeah more than absolutely yeah
so I I absolutely think if if they want
to have these non-discriminate look I
like the idea that public accommodations
don't discriminate against people based
on their religion let's uphold let's
hold them to it yeah well also and this
is so sickening and the reason this kind
of thing happens is because
when somebody is so debauched in porn
adult that they have to engage in the
most perverse possible sexual behaviors
to get any kind of thrill and they can't
resist those urges and temptations the
fact that there are human beings out
there who are so in control of
themselves that they're celibate and
pure is completely intolerable to them
that's why they hate nuns because a nun
is the thing in the world that they hate
most a pure woman a person who's capable
of being disciplined of displaying
self-control of displaying self-control
and especially when you're a grown man
in the world has no shortage of women
with more emotional and sexual restraint
than you when you're naturally supposed
to be an authority
doesn't feel so good to think about
right they can't they literally cannot
tolerate the existence of good women so
they need to mock them and that is why
nuns are being insulted gotta Sue and
any anybody who works in any way with
these organizations should immediately
be like you can get an injunction what
are they doing it's two days right the
game I think
they're doing the the none thing is in a
couple days I don't know but uh you can
get it I doubt it'll happen at this
point well they they canceled it then
reinvited them yeah and it was because
of the other side like we were supposed
to but like this is on it the left hits
you back but this is a violation of
California human rights law to openly
mock a religion yeah at a baseball at a
baseball game right so let them argue in
court why it's not mocking and then if
they win congratulations now anyone can
do any public display mocking any group
of people so I kind of laugh at this
kind of stuff too because being from
Texas
this just would never happen
but this would not happen at a at a at a
Dallas game this would have to happen at
Astros game this would never happen
because the people on the stands would
be apoplectic
and so my issue is now what what's
happened with the degradation of
California that this is even a
conversation and it's also good for me
to hear these kinds of things because it
makes me really very thankful that I
live in Texas okay because this is
absolute insanity but it's always the
vox populi it's always the voice of the
people and you are absolutely correct if
you are so dissatisfied with seeing
something like this we can't talk about
on a podcast the people there have to
show their disapproval and then vote
with their wallet and then vote with
their pocketbook to make sure that this
just stops or they sue them because they
should be offended by something like
this and by the way when the left you're
so right when the left gets offended
they go for jugular but it's over yeah
it's over but they also know that the
laws work in their favor like I'd be
interested to see if the lawsuit plays
out so the group of Christians say this
discriminatory this hate speech can't
believe they did this if I judge would
be like I don't really think that
there's enough uh weight to your claim I
think that there are some people who
really feel like Christians because
they're the majority religion in this
country don't feel the same
discrimination oh I matter we usually
don't say anything though either yeah we
let it go and it's time to stop letting
it go time to stop the law is the law
because the law and you also have to
realize that like you're not defending
yourself you're defending God you're
defending nuns you can't see this as
well I don't want to get offended there
I mean what is more illustrative of
punching down than insulting nuns women
who forego having a family to spend
their lives in the service of others and
you're mocking them the reason they're
mocking them is because they're weak men
and they're so effeminate that they
can't handle the fact that there are
women in the world stronger than them
which is why they mock them right these
are not nuns they're stronger than all
of these these gross little perverts if
it is legal to dress up like a nun in
this way mocking the religion
and a court says it's fine then anybody
could dress up like a trans person and
do this same thing and and mock them and
insult them like carry around baby dolls
and claim to be groomers the groomer
nuns or whatever they can claim we if
you're saying you don't want
discrimination you certainly can't
openly mock a group of people based on
their religion and they are we're not
we're not but they are they're literally
trying to degrade it I mean look they
the the rainbow is uh God's God's
covenant to no I believe correct yep I
see a lot of this on Twitter and now the
rainbow is a symbol of one of the seven
deadly sins it's really interesting to
me that they chose to go with pride to
represent their proclivities because
they I guess they want to be like I am
proud of who I well look you can be
accepting of yourself you have to be
angry with yourself but it is
interesting that they they push it to
you know Pride isn't typically a good
thing no it's not it's not you've all
seen a movie Seven you saw what happened
this and this is something that um but
no seriously though I'll joking aside
you know it's amazing how they would
pervert that to make it a Biblical thing
yeah in order to make it more acceptable
in their own eyes yeah well also I mean
I think it's actually kind of fitting
they call it pride because one thing
that Thomas Aquinas wrote was that when
a person becomes too prideful God will
withhold The Graces from them not to
fall into perverse sexual appetites so
that they will be humbled I think we
should we should uh sound of Interest
bring some rainbows back here
look I don't I don't care about what
they think it means if it literally is a
representation that you know guys think
whatever they want to think yeah this is
a free country right I was telling I was
telling James this last year I said you
should put a rainbow behind you
it's not even a joke I'm totally serious
well to be honest they would probably
not just because it's God's covenant but
because I wouldn't have like the little
trans arrow and BLM arrow and then like
Ukraine logo inside of it this is way
out of date we'll make a very beautiful
depiction of the Ark with a rainbow
saying God's covenant on it that you can
put up amazing I'd be so happy with that
let's let's do it let's do it then and
they'll be like oh it's the rainbow
right since that's back to you maybe but
to us it means something else it means
and that's fine you can believe whatever
you want but I don't know why Christians
have seeded that's that that simple
people who hate them exactly well
actually to be fair I actually don't
think they use the full rainbow let me
pull this up real quick I think there's
a slight difference yeah they did get
rid of some colors I believe that's very
discriminating did you know it used to
have magic colors I think it used to
have a stripe in it for Magic witchcraft
or something one thing that cracked me
up this was uh pointed out by some Anon
account on Twitter which most brilliant
observations are to be honest uh and
they they showed all of the different
iterations that the the flag had gone
under this pride flag had undergone in
the last several months they're like
isn't it so fitting that it's having an
identity crisis
all right we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member by going to
timcast.com clicking join us so you can
hang out in our members only uncensored
show and if you sign up at the 25 per
month level you can submit questions and
even call in to talk to us and our
guests Let's uh let's read what you got
Brian's here says make shrooms legal
okay
uh West Virginia is officially
legalizing recreational marijuana in
July wow really yeah if you drive down
uh 340 into uh Charlestown there's a
building they've been doing work on and
I and I I was like I saw them doing
construction and it says like cannabis
something on a county grown and then I
was like wait what and then I looked it
up and it's like marijuana will be
recreationally legal it's gonna be
recreational in Maryland too it'll be
interesting yeah are you sure that's uh
West Virginia not Maryland because West
Virginia West Virginia wow there is a
building they have constructed you want
to look it up real quick I'm looking it
up right now yeah there's a building
saying like dispensers or whatever the
same buildings in Martinsburg actually I
saw the same building there you go yeah
that's all that's all over the place
yeah there you go all right Raymond g
Stanley Jr says very smooth Tim I like
how you pretended to do a 10 a.m segment
just so you can practice your future
political campaign messaging I was
basically saying like
DeSantis lost a big opportunity with
face they they took this away from you
we tasted American greatness and they
ripped it away and since Joe Biden
became president the economy has been
falling your wages have been falling
your costs have been increasing your
border has been destroyed
and we it's like
instead he's just freedom is worth
fighting for I'm like uh
all right freedom is good thing Brody
yes Brody Nevis says my family is
thinking of moving to Florida so I would
appreciate if that DeSantis stays as
Governor yeah
who's uh who are they talking about
having run as governor
of Florida yeah I think we were talking
about maybe maybe it's secret we're not
supposed to talk about I don't know I'm
like didn't someone mention I am not
finding that uh marijuana is going to be
legal in West Virginia I'm seeing that
medical is legal here but not
recreational maybe I was wrong Tim just
made that they said that uh house bill
31 and the noise Candace Act was
introduced in 2019 but it's currently
stagnant
a pretty big CBD industry in West
Virginia and again medical is legal I'm
pretty sure
uh let's see I know Maryland is gonna
legalize recreational I saw that
building and I looked it up and I'm
pretty sure I saw something saying that
they were legalized I was like whoa wait
what
yeah don't know I heard I've heard that
Maryland is July 1st but I don't know
about West Virginia
huh maybe I was wrong
yeah whatever I'll look into it later
yeah but we were we were in Charlestown
and we saw this building that's a
dispensary and then I was just like wait
what and I'm pretty sure maybe they were
dispensing something else I think it's
CBD and medical probably CBD and medical
but yeah it's just Medical but what I
read was that it wasn't a for a few more
months so they may not have I'm not
finding it I have a I have a pick for
the next Florida governor who
buddy I swear with Byron Donaldson
o'byron oh yeah he's awesome he'd be a
great guy he was on the show right when
we were in Congress wasn't he he'd be
great would he do it
I think probably okay you're writing his
medical do it yeah in July of 2023
medicinal use I see no no no no no no no
no wait wait wait wait wait no this says
indicaonline.com says the requie the the
recreational use of cannabis by adults
is set to become legal in July 2023. wow
anywhere else but maybe uh
so this is for oh wait West Virginia's
recently joined the growing number of
states that legalized cannabis for
medical use the state's medical cannabis
program became operational 2021 while
the recreational use of cannabis by
adults is set to become legal in July
2023. wow
yeah this is uh Indica online
I don't know and and I saw a building a
dispensary so I was like okay and then I
pulled this up and that's what it says
yeah totally the recreation it's West
Virginia not Virginia in West Virginia
legalizing cannabis in West Virginia has
well thing popped up has been a
contentious issue with proponents
arguing blah blah blah under the laws
yada yada currently and then um with the
legalization of cannabis for
recreational use in 2023 West Virginia
is poised to become one of the latest
states to embrace the growing trend of
legalizing cannabis for medical and
recreational use
yeah well I think currently medical is
legal yeah it is currently legal right
and it's this uh Indica online I don't
know if it's the number one source or
whatever I don't know they wrote this
February 20th of this year it says in
July recreational will be legal
we'll see you guys
let's grab some more Super chats and see
what we got
S.A federali says I don't buy the
constant Khan media excuse good problem
to have we melted the servers this feels
like AWS throttling the qos and E1 ready
for net neutrality debates yet I asked I
am ask Bill o since Ian's part-time
um I just think Twitter couldn't handle
it uh we had another story we didn't get
into but the the head engineer resigned
yes following this we don't know why
but it's it's it's it's it's really
Korean I'm sorry man
Rhonda Santos message was very internet
esoteric it was it was very
understandable to us the hyper online
then when the Twitter space crashed at
about seven hundred thousand I mean it
was crashing at 300 000. for them to say
it's the possibly the biggest room ever
online is just like dude you can't come
in and talk to the internet and then be
wrong about the internet there's cringe
that's terrible PlayStation apparently
had a bigger live stream that day yeah
if they had done this the announcement
on YouTube he would have gotten way more
viewers it would have been absolutely
massive or if you've done it on
PlayStation that could have done like a
Minecraft stream or something yes
absolutely Elon didn't buy that though
right oh that's true maybe he has to
Neil Williams says is Sheamus wearing a
90s ball chain necklace or Mardi Gras
beads uh no so so what happened was I uh
my scapular broke so I just put my
rosary on under my shirt
oh it's a rosary interesting
what is it what are they what are they
saying s v s f v Raider says the
December's disciples are in desperation
mode they know it was weak too weak for
international leader confrontation at
this point Lake shows more strength no
longer looking to Rhino Ron in 2028 I'm
sorry man Rhino Ron de swampedus those
are way better names they're pretty good
then uh desanctus I don't even know what
that means not to be fair let's see
which one sticks Trump did praise Cuomo
over to Santa's response in Florida and
that was a huge Gaff almost literally
like
wait nursing home patients died yeah
yeah and then in the near post right
they run a big page where Cuomo's quoted
as saying like well they're all dead
anyway or something like that yeah yeah
Trump should not be praising Democrats
because it doesn't like Ron DeSantis and
this is the craziest thing you want to
win you be honest and you assert
yourself above a person so you say
something like if I was if I was Trump
I'd say Ron talk about a great Governor
I mean he had excellent and amazing
policies I worked with them a lot on
that and I'm really glad to see that my
endorsements paid off and we got such a
great leader
but I'm running for president and I've
got a proven track record and he doesn't
and Ron and Ron doesn't in Florida but
but the the strategy here is if
everybody if people who like Trump do
like DeSantis too and people who like to
Sanders do like Trump DeSantis isn't
winning by attacking Trump no and Trump
isn't isn't winning by claiming Cuomo
did a better job than decision I'll get
your point yeah yeah that's you know
just bro don't you don't don't defend
Cuomo like I'm sorry absolutely yeah
Matt colossa says Tim is it possible to
have an audio only live stream of IRL
somewhere too rather than just uploading
it afterwards
I don't know uh I don't know because for
the podcast platforms you have to just
upload them yeah we could we could
theoretically do it we were thinking
about doing a Twitter space where we
would just launch the space and then it
would just be the IRL account or the
timcast account just making the sound
and no one can chime in or do anything
just listen right and then it's on
Twitter yeah the issue with the podcast
like you said is they only want the
audio file uploaded maybe maybe we can
do it as a Twitter space somehow like
the general idea is turning the iPhone
on and pressing go yeah and then
everything you hear in the room the
ambient audio is I mean just the show we
can even just feed directly into the
iPhone itself and have those no they
don't have uh oh they don't pick up in
them oh wow it doesn't have the inputs
we can get an ox to lightning converter
I guess yeah that's what I was saying
towards it it is and then you can't plug
in any chart well I guess I can charge
it with them with the the wireless
charging oh true yeah you're good silly
another 100 device right yeah yeah yeah
all right
Corey Corey USMC 101 says this doesn't
make sense as a political science matter
DeSantis mathematically can't wait uh
wait Trump is 30 to 50 points ahead in
most polls you can't just make that up
only five percent of Trump's base can
stay home and throw away the general I
mean that's that's just it
you can't you can't recover I mean
maybe to be fair people are mentioning
that Trump was way down this early on
but we're talking about different
conversations exactly this is this is
Trump coming back he wants to be
president again it's on an open field
Sam Nguyen says wow who my rep Wesley
hunt my man awesome that's awesome
Justin Funk says loyalty to Trump is BS
the Republican primary is for the people
to decide who they want Trump isn't The
Once and Future King
no he's the god Emperor
I'm kidding I I agree I agree
um I I look forward to a primer I think
a primary will be strength and it will
be good for Trump I think it'll
strengthen the challenge is I think Don
Jr mentioned this are we going to spend
a billion dollars to win a primary
instead of spending on the general Joe
Biden that's it yeah
it's a resource it's a resource
constrained conversation we have far
fewer than they do
yeah
Golden Fleece game says to my fellow
Spud blood you should make a tune you
should make a tune referencing Captain
America Trump is the captain and he's
fighting Ron Red Skull after a few
punches Ron removes the mask and it's
just Jeb
look listen I don't have I have no hate
in my heart for all Ron I just I think
he's got to pick up some charisma
yeah
but is that something you're born with
can you really cultivate Charisma here's
the thing I don't know you can't you
probably can't cultivate Trump level
Charisma and if you can it takes years
and years but the level of Charisma
where you don't sound the way DeSantis
did when he was reading off that
announcement yeah I I think you can
probably practice and get better
let's record I want to read desantis's
uh opening video verbatim but instead of
saying I'm running for president I'm
going to say I am selling chickens Tim
do you remember Peter Francis geracy do
you know what I'm talking about yeah
anyone from the Chicago area remembers
anyone from the Chicago area members
there was this guy whose commercials
would come on at like 3 A.M and he was
he was his lawyer who's just very
monitored to go hi I'm Peter Francis
geracy I mean he got it did work
anyone anyone from that area will
remember him he just had this very um
monotone delivery and and it's what
DeSantis reminded me of
I think I think the DeSantis is very
charismatic in print like I love what he
has written I I love his statements when
I read them I think he hits all the
right points but the guy really has to
yeah where he announces first and as low
energy as possible and then gets into a
very esoteric conversation about the
narrative yeah yeah I was like dude
teleprompter that's the thing I just
felt like he was reading it's brutal
CJ McLean says Tim when Sheamus gets
cycled out you need to replace him with
a hard liberal that would disagree with
you on almost everything would make the
show more interesting I'm never getting
cycled out baby
but then I'll be back again later
there's not even a shimcast account what
do you mean the fake ad yeah there's no
shim cast no that's true I just made
that up yeah
the house of straws
iron Lord says Candace Owens for VP what
if Trump did pick Candace Owens wouldn't
it be funny yeah
d-man says Trump needs Carrie Lake as VP
someone that does not quit
perhaps I think uh I I I've said this
before I think she'd be an excellent VP
because she she has the Trump Vigor with
media attacked yeah definitely um
but you made a good point earlier about
wanting to win another state getting
that Vantage so you get a you get a VP
say Christy gnome then he gets South
Dakota or something like that he gets an
advantage based on who his VP is so but
maybe Carrie like pulls in a lot of uh
Arizona support
manifested Destiny says the idea of what
is presidential is a recent media
creative created narrative Teddy
Roosevelt threw people out of Windows
such a good point Jackson invited the
locals to eat a giant cheese wheel in
the White House lawn it's a false native
it politicians used to duel yes oh yeah
let's do it again and it was you think
things were worse because you know why
they got rid of you know they got rid of
dueling I was reading about it it was
because young woke people thought
dueling was was bad and then once as
they got older they banned it I'm
actually a little uh to be honest I'm a
little woke on that I think it's bad to
shoot at a person if it's not a direct
self dual situation wasn't always like I
was reading about like why would anyone
do that and it was because it was an
honor thing where you didn't actually
try to kill the other person yeah you
were just shooting off so I guess what
happened with Hamilton and Burr was that
uh Hamilton intentionally fires off to
the side like I'm a man of Honor I am I
am not afraid but then Bert was like
yeah
yeah it's like an honor thing like would
you even show up that was the point
exactly no no I I understand I
understand all that totally and the
young people were like this is so dumb
you shouldn't do you should make it
illegal we should ban guns and they're
like whoa go back home get rid of the
dude it was the big ask right exactly
but what is presidential matters today
because of of propaganda public
relations and mass media before these
things yeah you'd read in the newspaper
we were talking about this the other day
as someone said that uh was it you I
don't know who brought this up that uh
who if you if you listened to the debate
between Nixon and Kenneth oh yeah I
brought that up yeah everyone say it
again so in the uh kind of Infamous 1960
presidential debate everyone who
listened to it on the radio thought that
Nixon won everyone who saw it on
television thought that Kennedy won and
Nixon looked Nixon looked terrible
because
his points were were better uh you know
all the people on the radio at least
that that was the case but people didn't
like him it's really it's all about
presentation and he looked
was a ghoul compared to Kennedy
side was just it was Irish so he just
looked better
it's an established pack but I mean part
of it too was that he was then able to
continue to ride the I am the young
vibrant personality that's right we got
a good one here from CJ says rep hunt
what more can djt do to attract young
black men I'm fearful Biden will draw a
huge gen Z turnout just because Trump is
on the ballot
um he needs to continue to do exactly
what he's doing right now and talk about
his record and talk about the economy
talk about what we can do to get this
country back to the way it was before
covid and if he stays focused on those
topics stays focused on those issues
literally like black people like
American voters they want to hear about
are we going to secure the Border or not
are we going to have a Sovereign Nation
what are we going to do about inflation
are we going to stop Waging War against
our energy and oil and gas companies and
talking about what are we going to do to
get back to those things and staying
focused on that I think those kind of
just pragmatic terms with his already
popular Vigor yeah I think that will
that that will fare out very well people
are sick of living in poverty they're
sick of eight percent inflation what are
we gonna do to stop that right on
Igor kudin says I listened to your show
the day after on my way to work Ron Des
news fast make politics boring again
wow I don't want to slam around to say
this too much because I want to have
lots of different strong people going
forward into the future I don't want to
amen our entire future on one person
who's great but also you know only has
four more years as the president well
that's what I'm saying it's right
frustrating to watch this happen exactly
if it was job
hilarious I would think it was hilarious
yeah but because it's Rhonda Sanders
like oh you have so much potential
you've done so much good please don't do
this don't do this right I mean like and
I I I bash on Biden for being old and
basically lying about his health all the
time but Trump is 76 year olds he's
great it's full of vigor but he doesn't
have decades and decades ahead of him
the way that you know DeSantis or people
of his cow or of this age group do I
mean you're an example of this right
like we want to have lots of people
coming up the pike we don't want to be
tearing them down yeah we do and the
good thing about our party is if you
look at our bench compared to the left
right now
I'm doing pretty good I know did they
have I mean like they have AOC
like I said
I will say as far you know there's a lot
I disagree with him on especially like
the pro-life issue all the things I
would disagree with the Democrat on but
RFK as far as Democrats go I do find
them quite interesting and I like a good
amount and they won't even let them
debate every media Outlet calls him a
long shot like this is what I find
fascinating there must be a section of
their party that is sort of in line with
him he's attracting moderates some polls
show he's attracting Biden's voters away
from him he's denying him 20 I think
they have the problem the same problem
we do which is that they are shifting
from having uh people they they want to
see out they do want to see the bidens
out they want to see this little older
white male class out and replace them
with someone else but they aren't sure
where they're going I always find that
funny right like they're trying to do
with with old white guys and then their
top two finishers were Bernie Sanders
and Joe Biden but they don't like it but
now they're not happy about it yeah you
know they want to get rid of Joe Biden
because everyone's just so sorry by his
charisma
you know how much he's shaking up the
system he's a real chaos candidate
Ronaldo concerned about his Charisma oh
no we're back
come on man all right all right let's uh
let's reach Joe Biden would call him a
bad dude
a bunch of bad boys AZ static says how
pissed do you think desantises at musk
the Santa says blame but doesn't musk as
well curious for your opinion musk
should be roasted too in my in my
opinion
um Elon Musk I think is doing great work
he's got a lot he's got a very difficult
battle out of him I don't know how you
could be mad at him it's a technical
issue when these things happen I think
DeSantis made a mistake by launching his
campaign on Twitter agreed yeah if he
had launched it on YouTube he would have
had 4 million live viewers there would
have been no crash and he could have
done it with Elon Musk or anybody else
they could have simulcasted but Elon
wanted the exclusive and in their
inexperience they don't it's it's like
the Santa's campaign
his Charisma and his policy exemplify
their level of understanding of the
culture War very very well they have a
they have a surface understanding of
these things and they don't have any
core player advising them
they don't have a high level person to
be like Ron you're dry yeah you've gotta
you've got to do it again what they have
is you've you know I went on Twitter and
I read what people are saying I got a
good file I follow a good bunch of
people looks like you hit the points
there we go oh man Twitter it's so big
let's go with Elon Musk I would have
been like why
no I like why would you do that right
and then also videos how Elon is Elon
takes risks do y'all remember when he
was rolling out the Cyber truck yeah oh
that was incredible
um but we'll fix it later because that's
actually how he thinks yeah uh I
actually got to meet him at a retreat a
couple of years ago and it was really
kind of funny because I walked up to him
and I said hey man I just want to let
you know it's really nice to be one of
the only two African-Americans
that's Retreat you find that to be
really funny but he's the kind of guy
that that that thinks in like a
different way he'll blow up a rocket to
figure out how to make a better rocket
yeah you know he'll he'll he'll break
and that he doesn't view it as being
embarrassing he views it as a lesson
it's just data for him exactly and my
guess is he did the exact same thing for
his experiment like how far or how big
or how much bandwidth can Twitter hold
well let's find out by announcing this
presidency this didn't work but I bet
we'll get it right the next time all
right that's not his fault Tony Jade uh
sagas DeSoto from a fellow minority West
pointer and combat veteran thank you sir
for your continued service to our great
nation Go Army Beat Navy beat them
that's right ah Beat Navy thank you
Tanner Reeves says bongino played a clip
of Sheamus on his podcast today Potato
Man Sprouts Roots I love Potato Man
Sprouts Roots I love it yeah yeah I was
I was sad I missed them on Monday it
seemed like you all had a whole lot of
fun without me though so I guess it's
fine oh yeah it was really great because
we were like making fun of you the whole
time I know I I heard yeah Dan was like
who's that Irish guy that you guys make
fun of all the time I was like I was
born in Chicago like I'm not even from
Ireland they just wanted alcoholics yeah
I know
she was made
up about himself and then when we played
along he's like how dare you be racist
no I never made that joke you guys made
it no you walked in when I was watching
leprechaun
is a true story hold on there's a real
story I was watching leprechaun on the
couch for some reason just by myself and
Sheamus walks in he's like what are you
watching and he looks at the screen and
it's a guy turning into a leprechaun
eating a bunch of different kinds of
potato that actually happened today the
leprechaun bites the guy and he turns
Irish
and so he starts eating a bunches
and Sheamus was like what is This Racist
movie Garbage oh my gosh it's like
insanely offensive
okay we can make fun of Irish people
yeah exactly if he got like bitten by
someone of a different ethnic or racial
then started eating their food it would
be like this film is responsible for
genocide
so much I just but I cannot tell you
oh man oh behind this Congress thing
sometimes
took your advice she's homeschooling my
brother moved us out of California to
Texas we're glad we left California is
coming after her now please shout out my
GoFundMe for her Catherine Thrift I hope
you get chickens
you know some some of course that is by
the way curriculum that is that is from
Tim that's like the nicest thing I've
ever heard Tim say to or about anyone I
hope you get chickens that is like Tim's
highest compliment it's like I hope you
are blessed with many chickens
thank you that is like the Tim prayer
and may you receive many chickens
let's grab some more inspector tasty
says went to a drive-through liquor
store last weekend ordered a tall can of
Miller Lite the guy hands me a brown bag
I got home to find out he snuck me a Bud
Light they're literally trying to unload
their stock any way possible wow
unbelievable yeah they're giving away
for free
their stores are the QR code it's like
15 QR code buy it scan the code and then
we we mail you back up give it to you
yeah
because the beers costs money to get rid
of that's right if you go to liquor
store and you got a bunch of beer you
gotta hire someone to dispose of it or
send it back or something yeah so so
actually many of the Distributors that
actually uh butterwise was buying them
back yeah buying back expired beer talk
about embarrassing
Robert Knight says Tim Chase Bank is
having issues Zell and general
transactions Frozen Account Details
Frozen for the past four hours is anyone
else having Bank issues currently this
may be the beginning uh I don't know
maybe it's just you you just got to be
careful maybe your account is is you
know what if you just forgot your
password what if you like sounded the
alarm on a global financial crisis
because some guy forgot his password
it's like turned out he like forgot the
city he was born in when it was like
asking him the questions
that's right imagine if like Sheamus
came on this show and he was like it's a
disaster and we're like wow really and
then people start selling off stock and
they're moving their money and then
James goes oh wait I've got the
exclamation
foreign
with Matthew Murphy he says please as
the congressman ask the congressman
about the non-scientific racial quotas
for enrollment and clinical research per
FDA guidance omnimus budget Bill January
23 this will delay life extending and
saving oncology drugs from reaching the
market just to satisfy some Dei or d-i-e
bureaucracy I never heard of this I have
heard of this and again this gets back
to the root I think of what we were
talking about earlier and that is this
has got to we've got to get to the point
where this is a meritocracy where all
Americans first and everyone is treated
equally I got it we aren't perfect but
this is the infinite consequences of
this kind of behavior is that it then
disproportionately impacts another group
and that equally is Un-American yeah
they have issues with Chase Bank
actually really yeah okay so it's not
the exclamation point that's good no
it's not but let's be let's be cautious
about what we say here yeah yeah
done good
belief you sir all right or a wise man
that's trying to do my best leading
floating feathers Tim in regards to your
spouse's BF video and I want to clarify
it's a video about a guy whose wife has
a boyfriend not you know anyway he says
do you think this Lefty crap is the
cause of more middle-aged guys divorcing
from long-term marriages now more than
women once did I don't know about all
that but uh there's a video where a guy
he's bragging about how his wife has a
boyfriend well he's so cool but he says
she's not my wife because we don't use
gendered language she's my spouse and
she's a partner and I'm like bro partner
means two a partner is two people so if
your wife is a partner you're the person
who's out it's not you but he was like I
don't know why you think it's an insult
because your masculinity is as frail as
tissue paper or something bro if you
have to ask you will never know
yeah
well look it's not an insult my point
was this you're not insulting them by
saying what about your wife's boyfriend
they go oh he's great thank you because
they're into it they like it I know they
should just stop treating polyamory like
it's cool like imagine imagine I never
did I never treated and that's treated
like a trendy thing all of the dating
podcasts treat it like it's just a cool
alternative option imagine if somebody
went to Sheamus imagine if they went to
Sheamus and they were like oh yes
Sheamus how do you spend your Sundays at
church
that's exactly what it's like when you
talk to these lefties about their wives
boyfriends they're just like yes my
wife's boyfriend yeah okay they should
go just not space but they know it's
shameful deep down
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends it's the
best way to help they are trying to push
us down in the algorithm and silence us
but the only reason we survive is
because you guys share the show and I've
heard a bunch of stories so I really do
appreciate it you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast we're gonna have that members
only show coming up for you in a few
minutes so stick around do you want to
shout anything out to Congressman oh
please if you have any questions go to
my website
wesley4texas.com has all my handles on
it and again it's been an absolute joint
a pleasure to be on with you all anytime
please let me know it's about an hour
and 10 minute drive for me this is an
awesome experience learning absolutely
really appreciate it brother thank you
thank you and thank you so much dude
thank you for coming on this is great it
was a lot of fun anytime my name is
Seamus Coughlin I make cartoons I
actually did two about polyamory
recently one is called uh polyamory
explained in 15 seconds which was kind
of mean but pretty funny and then one
called polyamorous Grandma so uh
be releasing three cartoons next week on
Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday I think
you guys are going to enjoy all of them
so if you want to go over to Freedom
tunes and hit that subscribe button I'd
greatly appreciate it cool I'm Hannah
Claire bremel I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should go to timcast.com
click on the read tab see the work for
me and all of our other journalists uh
you should also follow at timcast news
on Twitter and Instagram it's the best
if you want to follow me personally you
can find me on Instagram at hannahclar.b
and on Twitter at HC bromelo thanks so
much and uh I really like today's
episode I think today is going to go
down it's like one of those sleeper
episodes that if you didn't see it you
kind of missed out so thank you
appreciate it thank you yeah Sheamus is
a rant yeah
you guys the congressman's reaction to
it he's over here
[Laughter]
you guys are so sweet all of his kids
are going to watch Freedom too
yeah it was a good one uh I'm surge.com
I'll see you guys on Twitter we will see
all of you in the members only
uncensored show in a few minutes on the
front page of timcast.com thanks for
hanging out